parent Miami's own as Lucca drives and
loses the ball it bounces back to him
then kidd-gilchrist scoops it up double
pump fake to beat the shot clock set
Murray clock winding down no pressure on
him
the shot late clock one shot fake
another shot fake and Bank with that
left hand excellent touch for him and he
needs to stay aggressive ahead of the
2-3 zone
seth Curry got free thirties his second
trail again
three balls going into this catchment
that we couldn't really be this man off
the dribble to get all the way to the
basket or running at him out of control
to take away the three South Korea comes
back with a third triple of six and a
half left third quarter four think is
gonna catch it a cracked open man is
curry for the three drills it with seven
points on the quarter and 16 for the
game
curry pull-up three and he got fat by
Derrick Jones two years a chance at a
four-point play continues to be super
hot beyond the arc that's his fifth beat
three and that is not an easy shot
because he caught it waited a second or
two before he released it it wasn't
completely in rhythm as a player that is
a touch right now on at 11:00 to 2:00
curry steps back and fires yes
seth Curry with four triples in the
Porter's six for the night the big time
run and really turned the moment around
up by 14 with just over five minutes
left
here's curry young Seth Curry has been a
perimeter beast in this game Mavericks
have won three of their last four on the
road they have 19 world wins of a foot
best road record and basketball courage
for three got open and he carries it
again